alex morgan set to go the USA soccer
forward and they had big match against
France
now they got England coming up tomorrow
and Alex Morgan joining us now from
France how is the weather in France by
the way it's hot unseasonable hot right
yes I don't think this is normal but
anyways with hot water so does the
weather factor at all I mean of course
but the time PM games are way better but
there's obviously can we players is
looking slow the game down at the end
you know which is which is not ideal do
you remember your first ever ever goal
my first ever ever oh my gosh no like
you movie 5 years old 6 years old
do you remember the feeling it well I
know when I got a little older I got
like 8 9 10 years old I remember the
feeling at that moment and I would say
it's pretty similar to the feeling that
I had my coracle with the national team
how good were you at eight years of age
no I think that I was pretty good I
don't know if my parents would say the
same or my scenario yeah I think I was
like I was athletic and I was a kid with
so much energy but I wasn't necessarily
the best like soccer player by any means
most goals you ever scored definitely
the game against Thailand
I can't even when I was 10 years old or
in high school or college I were scoring
five goals in a game
really I know it's it is kind of weird
right I mean maybe just happened but I
cannot ever remember do you ever feel
bad for a goalie no of course you can't
I mean you know definitely not that at
the same time I don't envy their their
job because
that takes a lot of guts to be in goal
for 90 minutes and the training that I
see Alyssa ask and ad doing everyday
that would not be something that I would
want to do so I give them mad respect
but is there a personality a certain
personality of being a goaltender oh
yeah I think so for sure I feel like the
vehicle keeper you have to be just like
ruthless and you have to be able to care
like for your body and your face on the
line it's a mindset for sure I think
there's there's something a little
different about goalkeepers I'm not
saying that's a bad different or a good
different it's just a little different
what have you had to fill in an
emergency situation I think Mia Hamm did
this before 20 years ago how would you
be as an emergency goaltender you know I
I would do whatever the team needed me
to do however I wouldn't say that I
would be the top two or three that the
coach would call upon to go and goal if
something like that happened you know it
was 20 a couple years like five or eight
years ago I don't remember we did it we
did kind of some goalkeeper tryouts just
in case it was like either the last
World Cup or the World Cup before that
and I didn't make the cut for the top
three so I just retired that that I get
you know in my mind of wild off she's
Alex Morgan US Women's National Team
forward co-captain and you got England
coming up tomorrow and it's your
birthday well we know what we know what
to get you for your birthday right yes
all the support and love and pride that
all of the fans could give and obviously
for us it's just doing our job it's
getting that win that would be the best
30th birthday present I could ever have
if I could get a celebrity to call you
for your birthday
anyone who would it be oh I don't know
oh god I hate being put on the spot like
this
I have no idea I mean I just I feel like
being here with my teammates all of my
family's here if there would be anyone
not could surprise me obviously I would
love for my husband to be here but
that's impossible why is it impossible
that he can't be there he's in season
with galaxy right now the game like yeah
I think they have a game the day or on
the day after on the fourth or something
so we would need something much faster
than planes to get him here
when's the last time Megan Rapinoe left
you speechless I think almost every day
you know leaves me speechless
it's something she does she says she
she's just she's a great teammate and
she's better the same and she loves good
banter she loves to joke around and just
you know it's it's fun having having
pino on this team and having played with
her for the last nine or ten years she's
tough man she really is she takes she
doesn't play anybody's fool out there I
really I loved watching her but I just
thought there's just something about her
I love that yeah love that about her and
it's great also for the younger players
just got to see someone who you know
speaks how they feel I got a little
chippy against France any words
exchanged you know no not really
I feel like this team is much like
talked through the game 13 and I think
it did get quite shaky I don't know if
all the calls went our way that should
last at the end of the day we were we're
obviously so happy to come out on top
because I don't know if you saw that
Stadium but it was rocking and the
French fans showed up for the for their
team so we definitely knew and felt like
we were Paris
playing against the home team I went out
on a limb and said you guys would win
the World Cup so make me look good with
my prediction okay Alex don't forget
about me that's the plan
you know okay I'll see you at the parade
Alex I love that thank you all right
thank you so much good night Alex Morgan
joining us from France the USA soccer
forward and co-captain and her
birthday's coming up tomorrow for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]